[MUSIC PLAYING]
MIKE COLEMAN: Hi, I'm Mike
Coleman, a developer advocate
at Google Cloud.
And today I want to talk
about some key considerations
you should be aware of when
looking to migrate existing
applications from VMs to
containers using Migrate
for Anthos.
In a couple of our earlier
videos on Migrate for Anthos,
we covered how to
use the Discovery
tool to discover
what applications
are a good fit for migration.
If you've not
checked those out you
may want to watch
them and come back.
You can find the links
in the description below.
For the remainder
of this video, I'm
going to assume that you've
already chosen an application,
run the Discovery tool and found
that your application is well
suited for migration.
While this is a
great place to be,
there are some
additional questions
you'll want to answer before
proceeding with a migration.
What should I do with any
databases I might be using,
how should I handle a VM with
multiple applications running
in it, how do my networking
requirements translate
to a Kubernetes deployment.
Let's start by looking
at handling multiple apps
or services running
in a single VM.
A common scenario we often
see is an application
where multiple components
are running on the same VM.
For instance, perhaps
you have a web front end,
a middleware component,
and a database
all running together in a
monolithic virtual machine.
Now ideally, and
with Kubernetes you
have a single process
running in each pod.
However by default,
Migrate for Anthos
will not create a
separate container image
for each service running in VM.
Since Migrate for
Anthos will try
to migrate each running service,
what you do in a situation
where you have multiple
application components
is to ensure that only
one is running when
you run the migration process.
For instance, shut down the
middleware and the database,
run Migrate for Anthos, and
capture the web front end.
Then shut down the web
front end and the database,
run Migrate for Anthos and
capture the middleware.
With those two components
migrated into containers
you'll need to decide
what makes the most
sense for your database.
With the database
tier you first need
to decide whether or not
you're dealing with a mission
critical component.
In some cases, you might
be migrating or configuring
a dev test deployment
of your application
or perhaps your
production application
is configured as
a monolith and you
don't want to break out
the separate components.
Now you realize, of course,
that this configuration doesn't
offer you the ability to
easily scale or provide
fault tolerance, but
it works for what
you're trying to accomplish.
In this case, you would
use Migrate for Anthos
to migrate the data to
a persistent volume,
attach that volume to the
pod at the appropriate spot
in the file system.
If it's possible to migrate
your database to Cloud SQL,
that's a great choice.
You can use Google Cloud's
database migration service
to migrate the data, then
configure your application
to use Cloud SQL or other
managed database service.
From there, you can
start to benefit
from the advantages of running
your database on a managed
service offering.
Now if Cloud SQL is not a
fit, then your next option
could be to run your database
natively on Kubernetes.
You would build a cluster
and install and configure
the database software
using Kubernetes Stateful
Set and persistent volumes.
Then use Migrate for Anthos
to export the data from the VM
to the new database.
Finally, if running the
database on Kubernetes
is not a good fit, you could
migrate the database tier
into a Google Cloud
Compute Engine VM using
Migrate for Compute Engine.
There's a great blog
post up on our site
providing some
additional details
on how to decide where
to run your database.
We'll put the link in
the description below.
Now that you have
individual images
for each of your
services, you'll
want to think about networking.
In many cases different services
within an application are
accessed using a DNS
based resource name. ,
However when migrating to
Kubernetes you'll use a service
name.
A good recommendation is to
choose short, yet descriptive
service names and ensure
your services are all
running in the correct
Kubernetes name space.
One way to handle the move
from DNS names to service names
is to provide your service names
via a Kubernetes config map.
So let's take a look at
using that config map
to alter the service discovery.
So I have an application
that I migrated over,
a service and an application.
So if I do a get
services here, you
will see this ledger
monolith service.
That came from a virtual
machine using Migrate for Anthos
but I have not changed
the DNS mapping
to Kubernetes service mapping.
So it doesn't work.
So I'm going to
go ahead and go in
and we're going
to open the editor
and we're going to
edit the config map.
And we're just going to
remove these DNS suffixes.
And when we do that,
that will take that
from being a DNS based name
to the Kubernetes service
name, which is
ledgermonolith-service.
So let me do this last one here.
And then we'll save that out
and move back to our terminal
and let's clear the
screen and we're
going to go ahead and
apply the config map.
And that's going to
update the services
on how they communicate.
So if we clear that,
now what we need to do
is we need to restart
our pods and we'll
do that by deleting
them and then
they'll recreate automatically.
So we'll delete them
and then let's come up
and let's watch those
pods get reloaded.
And this will take a second,
so I've sped up the video
and then now we can
bounce out here and let's
take a look at our services
and make sure we've
got the right IP address.
So we'll do a get service
and there's that IP, we'll
move up here into our browser.
We'll do a refresh
and you can see
that it's actually working now.
So that is using a
config map to move
from DNS based name resolution
with a virtual machine
to Kubernetes service
based name resolution using
the internal Kubernetes
service discovery mechanisms.
As an aside, when dealing with
sensitive configuration data,
you want to take advantage
of Kubernetes secrets.
For instance, if you need
to provide a password
to connect to the database,
you can store that
in a Kubernetes secret
rather than in a config map.
Check the Kubernetes
documentation
for more information on how
to configure and use secrets.
Now the next thing to
consider is controlling access
to your application.
By default, the deployment
spec generated by Migrate
for Anthos contains a
suggested headless service
object of type cluster IP.
This means no load balancing
and a single cluster internal IP
reachable only from
within that cluster.
In the case of our
web front end service,
we want to change that
to the type load balancer
to allow external access.
You should also consider using
some of Kubernetes network
policy features
to restrict access
to your various
application tiers.
For instance, you might want
to use network policies that
allow only the web
front end to talk
to the middleware tier
and another policy that
allows only the middleware
tier to talk to the database.
We've hit a few
of the highlights
with regards to
things you should
consider as you plan
your VM migration using
Migrate for Anthos.
To learn more about
Migrate for Anthos,
be sure to check out the Migrate
for Anthos documentation.
And this is one
video in a series,
so be on the lookout for other
Migrate for Anthos videos
and like and subscribe
to be notified
as we add additional content.
[MUSIC PLAYING]